esse sou eu
aos 10 anos de idade exatamente a idade
que eu tinha quando o meu irmão me fez a
seguinte pergunta daniel o que acontece
depois da quarta série e não tinha
parado para pensar sobre isso ainda mas
eu respondi foi bom
depois da quarta série você vai para a
5ª série
depois da 6ª 7ª 8ª série e aí você
terminar o ensino fundamental
aí você faz três anos do ensino médio um
ano de cursinho e aí você vai para a
faculdade mas não deve lembrar disso mas
eu por alguma razão nunca esquece
mas hoje quando eu volto pra esse
episódio eu entendo uma coisa que não
podia entender na época que essa
resposta que eu dei pro meu irmão na
verdade revela uma grande questão da
educação brasileira
eu fui começar a perceber isso só seis
anos atrás eu estava numa sala de aula
com 168 pessoas olhando pra mim pela
primeira vez esperando ansiosamente
pelas minhas primeiras palavras
foi no segundo ano da faculdade no curso
de biomedicina na universidade federal
de são paulo
eu tinha acabado de ser aprovado para
ser professor de inglês do cursinho
comunitário do meu camps o cursinho
pré-vestibular junina malásia
a idéia desse projeto que nós chamamos
carinhosamente de cuja é preparar alunos
provenientes do ensino público alunos
carentes para prestar os grandes
vestibulares isso através de um curso de
revisão do estatuto todo o conteúdo do
ensino médio ao longo de um ano
mas eu não gosto muito desses termos
porque eles estão muito longe de
representar a verdadeira história desse
projeto ao longo dos seus 16 anos o coxa
tem recebido alunos de diversos com
diversas características mas algumas
delas em comum eles são alunos da escola
pública
eles são alunos que moram na periferia
de são paulo às vezes há mais de duas
horas do cursinho seus pais trabalham
muito para conseguir pagar as despesas
de casa e ao mesmo tempo custear o
transporte desse aluno até o cursinho
fora uma série d
as questões familiares e pessoais que
são importantes para a educação desse
aluno mas a característica mais
importante de todos esses alunos que
chegam no cuja é que eles têm um sonho o
sonho de ir para a universidade
o sonho de ser médico biomédico
engenheiro matemático físico mas o
grande que a grande questão é que esses
alunos ou em ao longo de toda a vida que
eles não são capazes que essa que essa
realidade não é pra eles que pessoas
como eles não vão para a universidade
é muito difícil você sonhar quando todo
mundo disse pra você que o seu sonho não
faz sentido nenhum e é muito pior quando
quem fala isso pra vocês são seus
familiares em um porque eles não se
importam com você mas porque na verdade
eles não te protegendo de você fugir de
uma realidade que a única que eles
conhecem bom é assim que esses alunos
chegam no cujo com um mínimo de
esperança com uma coragem que eles ainda
não sabem que têm e logo no começo do
ano eles precisam encarar toda a
defasagem do ensino que eles tiveram até
então quando esses alunos chegam ou cuja
eu e os demais membros do projeto
entendemos a grande responsabilidade que
é empregada cada um de nós e aí nós
fazemos tudo que está ao nosso alcance
nós damos aulas plantões de dúvida com a
melhor de dati que nós conseguimos
preparando o nosso próprio material
exercícios simulados chamamos
professores da própria universidade para
vir conversar com os alunos sobre
aprendizado eficaz sobre o controle de
ansiedade
nós fazemos tudo isso inclusive
atualmente contamos com atendimento
psicológico porque nós sabemos o quanto
isso é importante para o nosso aluno e
tudo da forma mais descontraída que a
gente consegue
e o que a gente pode imaginar sobre
esses alunos que acontece com esses
alunos o que acontece com eles quando
eles chegam no cursinho é uma realidade
muito difícil
ele tem muitas questões e às vezes essas
questões passam pra gente e nós temos
que lidar com elas de alguma forma esses
alunos chegam o cursinho e mostram pra
gente porque nós estamos lá quando na
verdade o que a gente queria fazer o
contrário quero ajudá los
eu entrei no clube porque eu gostava de
dar aula mas foi no dia que eu entendi o
que isso de fato significava porque é
muito mais é muito incrível ver todas as
operações que esses alunos conseguem
realizar
e essas operações já são sucesso
independente da aprovação desse aluno no
vestibular
é incrível ver que aquele aluno que não
sabia tabuada hoje consegue discutir e
resolver uma questão de logaritmo com a
maior naturalidade do mundo
aquele aluno que nunca teve geografia
hoje consegue discutir questões
políticas com muita propriedade
esses alunos chegam no cuja lidam com
toda essa dificuldade mas pode ser um
pouco difícil falar assim lidam com
dificuldade que dificuldade é essa
os alunos que nós recebemos no cuja
chegam aqui no cursinho e aprendem a
tabuada aprendem regra de três
eles têm aulas de física geografia e
inglês pela primeira vez na vida
esses alunos chegam no cursinho e
descobrem muitas coisas que eles já
deviam saber antes
muitos deles trabalham ao longo do dia
para custear a ajudar em casa ou até
mesmo pra pagar o transporte dele até o
cursinho
muitos desses alunos
às vezes
compartilham longe do colega porque eles
não têm trazido de casa
é muito triste ver isso mas o que nós
encontramos nesses alunos é o todo o
empenho e tudo o que é necessário para
eles enfrentarem essa grande realidade
esse é sobre essa grande desejo que eles
sempre tiveram e a grande questão
por trás desses alunos os alunos
ingressam no vestibular
eles vão a eles chegam até onde eles
sempre quiseram não por uma questão de
mérito mas foi uma questão de
oportunidade e o cuja tem conseguido
ofertar essas oportunidades para esses
alunos
e aí quando a gente volta pra um porque
eu tinha falado para o meu irmão há 17
anos atrás porque eu um garoto de 10
anos que até então só tinha estudado no
ensino público via o cursinho como parte
da minha formação básica por que razão
eu não achava que o ensino fundamental
eo ensino médio seriam suficientes para
mim
se nós olharmos é para a lei de
diretrizes e bases da educação nacional
de 1996
uma das finalidades do ensino médio é
preparar o aluno para próprio trabalho e
cidadania para o aprendizado contínuo e
também para qualquer perfeição para se
adaptar a qualquer aperfeiçoamento que
ele deseja fazer depois
o que nós vemos no cuja é que o ensino
médio falha exatamente nisso na vida de
muitos jovens que não tem cão diz
condição de acesso ao ensino privado
se nós olharmos para o ideb o índice de
desenvolvimento da educação básica
desde 2005 o ano em que se tem o
primeiro dado esses alunos
esses alunos
os alunos da escola pública têm um
desempenho inferior aos alunos da escola
privada e quando nós olhamos para o enem
o exame nacional de ensino médio
esse panorama não é diferente e hoje o
enem é uma das principais formas de
ingresso no ensino superior
como havia dito essa conquista dos
nossos alunos é uma questão de
oportunidade e cuja tem conseguido
oferecer essas oportunidades para esses
alunos
eles chegam no cujo e fazem as suas
descobertas
é assim que o jovem carente tem feito as
suas descobertas
ele descobre a paixão dele pela física a
paixão dele pela matemática ele descobre
o talento dele escrever tudo que ele já
devia ter descoberto antes mas o que me
preocupa o que me preocupa de verdade é
que o cuja consegue receber uma pequena
parcela dos jovens o que acontece com
todos os outros jovens que não têm
acesso ao cuja iniciativas semelhantes o
que acontece com eles
as oportunidades estão sendo oferecidas
por cursinhos pré-vestibulares cursinhos
pré vestibulares que são classificados
como cursos livres porque de fato eles
são cursos livres e as oportunidades
elas na verdade são importantes na vida
desses alunos porque ele elas aproximam
o meu aluno de uma realidade que é a
realidade da qual ele faz parte
aproximam esse aluno de um mundo que eu
estava distante mas ao mundo em que ele
vive
e aí no cursinho que ele vai se
apropriar de conhecimento é no cursinho
que ele entende o papel social que ele
entende a importância de pensar
criticamente e como fazer isso e eu
convido vocês imaginem como seria viver
num mundo em que todos nós tivéssemos
uma educação de qualidade como seria
viver num mundo em que cada um
e nós conseguir se pensar criticamente
entendesse a importância da saúde e da
ciência da educação da inovação como
seria viver nesse mundo é com esse mundo
que é o sonho hoje e pode ser um pouco
contraditório mas nesse mundo que vocês
imaginaram não existe a necessidade de
existência de projetos como cuja porque
a educação básica consegue oferecer uma
educação de qualidade para todos que
precisam
e exatamente para chegar exatamente para
chegar nesse lugar nesse mundo que vocês
imaginaram o primeiro passo é que essa
realidade que nós vemos hoje na educação
seja incômoda não somente para
educadores ou para pessoas envolvidas na
educação
mas essa realidade que nós vemos hoje a
educação tem que ser incómoda para cada
um de nós é cada um de nós e podem até
me dizer danilo isso que você tá
sonhando é muito tópico é muito distante
mas se tem uma coisa que eu aprendi com
os alunos do curso ao longo destes anos
é que realidades podem sim ser
transformadas e que sonhar não só vale a
pena
como faz todo o sentido porque dessa vez
seria diferente
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]